what was he like what was how he like
when you were like five years old five
years old great yeah yeah I traveled
with him there's a huge spread between
my brother and I and so when I was the
only child I would travel with him when
he did gigs and I went all over the
country with him but when I was older he
sucked how did he suck why did you suck
super super super controlling yeah um I
didn't have a door on my room he took
the door off we fought all the time he
pulled me out of every friend's house
like he would show up find out where I
was call the cops when he couldn't find
me pull me out of the house way let me
just I was expecting the opposite
weirdly I was expecting you to say it
was like the group she traveled with the
group that her were her friends she's
making it seem like a little like I'm
over the top you are I I think there's
three you over the top three movies made
about your friends and what was
happening at the time with the people
that you were hanging with is that was
it The Bling Ring that's after no but no
they were oh yeah they were a little bit
after which one was what was a little
bit after bling was a little after but
those are the same they went to my
school that was the same really uhhuh
and they were just cracked out at school
Alpha Dog you know that movie uh-uh oh
or 13 Alpha Dog the one with um
Justin murdered Jessie James he murder
Mur he murdered the kid no I haven't I'm
really I'm really bad at Movies I've
seen like no movie ever but this is you
fall asleep in movies honestly yes
and my ADHD so bad podcast I'll get on
Tik Tok right in the middle of a movie
my ADHD is so bad and do a dance no no
no no not making them watching them um
can you imagine you're in a movie and
somebody sets up a ring honestly I can
in today's generation honestly actually
funny I'm doing a Tik Tok so what your
friends murdered people not my friends
hold on they were not my friends I just
was at their house and knew them from
time to time they were not my friends
friends but it was like the same kind of
crowd so does that sound seen them at a
distance that's a little [__] crazy
that's wild yeah and the drugs lot of
drugs I am so good now I love that no
you're you you give so good you are I
have two I
[Music]
give